today we're talking about how to get
your YouTube retention at 70 this is
important
now become the game for any social
platform it's honestly now much less
about how many subscribers and followers
you have
and instead it's about how good a job
you do at holding somebody's attention
on the content that you're putting up
and so for YouTube one of the biggest
things that I've been preaching for the
past I don't know how many years is
focused on the one minute retention
where are you at one minute if at one
minute you can hit 70 retention and it's
a decent enough video like it's 10
minutes plus you have a great shot of
that video blowing up and so today we're
going to talk about how to do that both
for YouTube but then also for tick tock
and other platforms you've got a message
all of us here we have a message right
we have a message in our heart that we
want to get out to the world and in
order to make that happen you have to
capture someone's attention really
quickly and hold it especially for that
first minute because if you can do that
people will watch the rest of your video
but if somebody's landing on your video
they have no idea who you are and you
can't capture that attention quickly
then you will not be rewarded with the
views from Tick Tock from YouTube
whatever platform so I'm gonna pop in
I'm gonna share my screen and we are
going to dive into it okay let's go so
keep your retention at 70 at one minute
so first let's talk about what is the
retention curve what is 70 retention
mean
for uh for people who've been with us
for a while you know what that means for
any new members for every video that you
put up on your YouTube channel it'll
show you what the retention is that
means how many people are still watching
what percentage of people are still
watching the video and the goal if you
really want a video to blow up is to it
one minute the one minute Mark have 70
of the people who started the video
still watching it this is free this is
all baked into YouTube all the analytics
are there you can easily see how every
video is doing and it's less about what
you think is good or what your friends
or family think is good and what
actually is good and so when people say
oh I make really great videos I don't
understand why YouTube's not promoting
them like okay let's take a look at your
honest retention curve and you see that
at one minute it's like 20 it's like
well you lost all your audience so it's
not a good video for what people want
yeah it doesn't mean that you suck it
just means you have to develop the
skills to learn how to make better
content
and this is factored into any any
platform right it's less about how many
likes and comments anything gets it's
about how much time are people spending
on your content on the platform
YouTube's goal Tick Tock skull
Instagram's goal Etc is to keep you on
their platform for as long as possible
so if you're having a great job keeping
people on your video on their platform
they will continue to promote your
videos
so this is what the curve looks like and
what you'll typically see is in the
first minute it tanks and then
afterwards people just keep watching
it's a slow slow slow drop right here's
a slow drop for me so we made it on
August 10th and then it went live August
17th right so still a couple weeks ago
and you can see at the one it's such a
long video it's an hour and a half I
couldn't get it to one minute but at one
minute 46 so almost two minutes in we're
at 66 percent
retention that means 34 of the people
who are watching the video left the
video in the first minute 46.
and that 66 percent are still watching
it this is the one piece of data that
you want to be obsessing about over your
videos this is it there's so much data I
love it I love playing with I love
looking at everything
don't get stressed out overwhelmed this
is the one thing that you want to pay
attention to though and so if I look at
one minute this video is just over 70
I'm at almost two minutes over 66
percent so this is a really good video
right for a video that's an hour and a
half long to be at 66 percent at almost
two minutes this is really good so
whatever we did here was really really
really good you can see what happens is
suggested is now where the video starts
to blow up so this is live I just took
the screenshot five minutes before going
live with you today you can see it's got
15 000 views in the past 48 hours and
where's it coming from suggested this is
where we want to play this is a YouTube
suggesting our videos and what you we
usually find is looking at two weeks
looking at a month two months three
months out is where suggested really
starts to blow up so don't freak out if
your video doesn't do well out of the
gate I don't care how my video does at
launch I care about how it does for
years because that's why YouTube is so
powerful the videos you make now will
live forever so this video has 95
000 views in two weeks and judging on
how well this is going right 66 at two
minutes this is going to be a million
view video
because the intro is really good
so the first minute is awesome
okay so this shows up for all of your
videos
so you want to be paying attention to
the audio detention curve on every video
and you can see where you're struggling
where it's not working if you ever see a
big drop like a tanks whatever you did
there is no good we need to fix it if
you ever see a big spike it means people
re-round to watch it again and that
means you did something really good keep
doing that that's amazing
so
this is not just a YouTube thing so
we're focused for most this presentation
on the title was 70 at YouTube this is
not just a YouTube thing guys this isn't
everything this is people if you want
eyeballs on your content that you are
making to impact lives other people
around the world this is one of the most
important sessions that you will ever
sit in on that might be it sounds
hyperbolic but it's true because
this is every platform now most most of
the other platforms won't give you the
data but Tick Tock does as well and
here's two tick tocks that um are I put
up side by side both are about a minute
this is 55 seconds long this is 51
seconds long this is from my personal
account
right 50 51 seconds long 55 seconds long
Tick Tock will show you second by second
where people are falling off this video
sucked right like look how much that
retention is tanking it's falling apart
and as a result we had a thousand plays
right one thousand one hundred twenty
six plays this video is doing way better
and look at the difference
almost 11 million plays
it's a big difference
and the strategies that you can use on
Tick Tock are similar that you can use
on YouTube but the retention is the big
Difference Maker it's no longer about
your followers it's no longer about the
hashtags that you're using it's about
how good a job are you doing in keeping
their retention and so looking at this
graph is critical
a lot of people are making the wrong
plays they're going in and say oh my
Tick Tock didn't take off oh my YouTube
didn't take off what's going on I must
be using the wrong hashtag I must be
using the wrong title maybe my thumbnail
is wrong and those could be not hashtags
but title thumbnail could be but it's
usually this you're just not doing a
good enough job or holding the retention
yet
yeah right this is a skill that we can
work on that's what we're going to talk
about in today's session uh it's so
exciting okay now let me tell you this
nobody hits 70 consistently nobody not
me I I worked with every channel in
entrepreneurship personal development
thought leadership nobody hits 70
consistently
it's the it's the impossible goal that
we're shooting towards right that one
that I showed you that's amazing that's
going to be a million plus view video
but not all my videos go off and do that
and so I'm still learning myself I'm and
every time I learn something I'm
teaching other people as well and
teaching you guys so don't stress out if
you're not there yet it's it's just what
we're aiming for this is this is the
most important metric on YouTube because
if you can get them to stay for that
minute they'll watch the rest of the
video tracking it becomes important and
here are the things that we track so
this is something that we track for
every video that we put up on our
Channel
the date of the video
the video ID and links we can go and
find it one minute where is it at
seventy percent what series is it a part
of and then what notes are we doing to
try to make it better and these are
different tweaks and changes and updates
who edited it we have multiple editors
on the team so what did we do on this
video so what I'm going to do is go back
with my team and look at okay why did
this video do so well
and what's going to happen is in my
notes It'll say who edited it it'll say
what we tried what we tested what we're
working on new ideas that we we
implemented and a lot of the new ideas
may not work you know you might try
doing something outside you might try
um doing something with a different
camera you might try living with a
powerful opinion you might try having
some music you might try all sorts of
different things to try to make the
video do better but you have to track it
and this is where we used to suck at
this we weren't tracking what we did
differently and and we've done like 15
000 videos or something so it's hard to
know all the things we've tested and
tried already but this is something that
we obsess over so we just have a
spreadsheet and it's very basic
spreadsheet and it just has this
information on it so for every video
that you put up
you should I would recommend looking at
where are you at one minute and what did
you try differently if you have
different series cool you can put that
in there if it's all the same like
series could be you reacting to a video
you doing leadership piece you're doing
a q a series you're doing an interview
lots of different series that you could
have on the channel but what is so
different about this video versus the
others right so if I can go to this
video and see what was different about
this intro
so that I can go and apply it to my
other videos
because again once you get past the
first minute it's usually the small the
slow decline so it's fine there's
nothing wrong with it being that
whatever this is what is that 20 20
something percent at the end of the hour
and a half that's fine don't stress
about that this video will have a
million views it's the first minute so
what do we do differently same thing for
The Tick Tock right and looking at this
one versus this one what do we do
differently why was the first tick
tock's a lot more aggressive right I
mean the whole video is just a minute so
what do we do in the first few seconds
to keep people's attention versus
this one which was not as a good
objectively just was not as good people
didn't like it
super pumped for the topic we're going
to get into today about how to how to
start actually selling and getting
awareness and eyes on the products and
service that you have are we ready for
today's topic can we dive in we're ready
all right let me let me share my screen
let me get this going so how to Market
your programs I was super excited when
this one came in
uh because we've talked a lot about how
to get attention how to create content
how to go live now we're talking about
how to actually start to monetize in
Market our programs and especially if if
you've had a hard time selling things uh
if you have a hard time asking for money
if you have a hard time pitching
yourself uh this is for you because
we're gonna we're gonna give you some
automatic strategies as well on how you
can start to make money from all the
content that you're putting up so the
first big idea and we've talked about
this before but today we're going to go
deep is
whatever you want to make money doing
show me the process of you doing it
right so big strategy number one and
this is not just something I'm sharing
with you guys this is what I share with
some of the biggest bigs in the industry
show me the process of you doing the
thing that you want to get paid to do
how are we going to do that it's
understanding that by bringing value to
people and making it public
you're selling without selling
there are some people here who have no
problem selling like yeah I love selling
it's great I have no problem picking up
the phone and cold calling people and
other people have a much harder time I'm
one of the ones who have a harder time I
hate calling up and say Zen you got to
go buy my Movie Makers program right now
uh so how do you then stand out well you
show the process of you bringing value
to other people
and it doesn't just help that person it
helps everybody else watching
so whether you're selling the coaching
Services mentoring books and we're going
to dive into exactly how to do it uh but
that's the concept like what do you want
to sell just think of everybody what do
you want to sell right now what's the
goal what do you want to sell what do
you want to make money this year doing
and then how can you show me the process
of you doing it not the documenting the
process of you doing it but the actual
process of you doing it so what I mean
by that we talk about document versus
crate before but
if you want to be a coach the document
in the journey is showing me what you're
doing with your website and how you're
starting and why you're doing it and how
how day one is for you when you have no
business and all that stuff and you can
get into some of the sneak peek behind
the scenes but what I'm more talking
about is if you want to be a coach I
want to see you coaching
I need to see you doing the thing
do the thing that you want to get paid
to do and show what happened live a lot
of you guys want to be coaches amazing I
love it you need to have a regular
coaching series you need to start
booking people on your shows to not just
have a conversation that can that's fun
but I need to see you coach them and
help them get a result if you want to
start making money as a coach so it's
not just you saying hey I do coaching
it's not just Brian coming in and say
hey I do relationship coaching I need to
see Brian helping somebody through a
relationship problem and how to overcome
it
okay if that's how you want to start
making money
okay mentoring uh this is now more this
guy is Kyle menko right I sponsor him
he's he's a League of Legends gamer he
coaches me on gaming and I coach him on
life and growing his business and and
part of that is every three weeks
normally he comes onto my show and it's
an Instagram live that we turn to a
YouTube video and that also gives him
promotion and exposure for what he's
doing and also uh shows off me being a
mentor
without me how I don't have to then say
guys I'm a mentor for people you can see
it you can witness it you can experience
it happening
right so this is what I want you to
start to do now if I I don't actually
sell coaching and mentoring
I like to I just like the help and it's
it's a way to make it scalable right uh
but if that's your business then you
definitely need to be showcasing you
mentoring and coaching people
live format and I love the live format
into a public video on YouTube client
stories so this is awesome Pablo here in
the house who is I think the first one
on here under this live live stream
today here welcome Pablo uh you can have
your clients come on and you can you can
tell their story and talk about why they
bought your book why they join your
thing not make it a sales pitch but give
them value right so here Pablo's holding
up built the serve you know I don't have
to
I don't have to tell Pablo hey Pablo uh
please say something good about built to
serve on my on our IG live together
because he likes it I mean he enjoys the
book because Ian enjoys the book
hopefully a lot of you guys enjoy the
book for for those of you who've done
movement maker sessions with on my
Instagram same thing you you hopefully
are finding value in movement makers and
when it comes out you talk about it and
and that's the the process that's the
point you bring your clients on you do a
session with them and they're going to
say good things about you unprompted
unscripted not like please make sure you
give me a five-star review right but
because they love what you're doing
they're gonna always say amazing great
things so think about not just your
not just random people that you're
coaching but your current clients and
how can you have them come on and not
just be a testimonial sales pitch but
how can you have them tell their story
give them some exposure to your audience
make them feel seen her recognized and
also ask questions relating to whatever
they bought from you relating to
whatever they did with you that could be
value for the audience but it's also
showcasing what you do and why you're so
great
challenge is another great one take
people in on a challenge so we're doing
the 100 video challenge which is awesome
and if you're on it great enough not get
on it you don't have to do one a day but
post your videos we want to see them
come to life
um Zane the man uh and I are doing a
90-day no sugar no junk food challenge
we're on day 76 I think Zane we're
getting close it's almost it's almost
done Terry joined so Terry here in the
house too uh decided to join us and and
sharing content to
people's Instagrams right so Zan Terry I
and others are sharing their results and
their progress so day 57 checked off now
this is something that I give away for
free but it could be a product
like that could be something that I sell
hey if you want people ask me all the
time how do I get the the sheet that you
Zan and Terry are using how do I get it
I want that myself like well like Evan
carmichael.com flexiex.pdf
like you could just go get it now if I
really wanted to that could either be
something where I capture their email to
get like hey if you give me your email
I'll give you the flexi X calendar right
uh or two it's it's a paid product
that this is a little nicer it's
laminated or something or gets shipped
to you and this is the this is a package
product right but if you have some kind
of challenge or some kind of process and
you're showing you and other people
going through it other people will want
to join the challenge too
uh this year is up because I did
um a book challenge for my first book
your one word once it came out
I did a weekly
live on my YouTube channel uh book club
it's kind of what Zayn's doing right now
private with people I did a public book
club once a week for however many
chapters there are in my book I don't
know 12 12 weeks or whatever
um and I just did it live and I didn't
repeat it and I didn't do it again it
was a one-time thing and so it's hey if
you want to join me
come back for next week finish reading
up the chapter two and we'll go through
this together I'll answer your questions
and I'll I'll I'll help you and so it
puts some urgency on it right and then
again they're in they're in my process
they're connected to what the book I'm
ultimately trying to sell the book
so if they know that they get access to
me doing a challenge I can help sell the
book so think about whatever it is that
you want to sell and then how can you
package it in some kind of challenge
that you're doing together either as a
one-off or it's a repeat thing that
you're doing ongoing right so that once
the 12 days are up for Zane's book club
that we're doing for build to serve it's
I think 12 weeks and then and then it
repeats again
okay new 12 weeks starting new 12 weeks
starting new 12 weeks starting right so
how can you turn whatever you're selling
into some kind of challenge
with with some urgency on it that makes
me want to stick around join in and be a
part of your process next show The
Journey when I was writing my first book
your one word I made over 40 videos of
my journey
so the first ones were like this about
my book I am about to launch a book hey
I'm getting the book I didn't have
anything written yet then as I was
writing the book I did QuickBook updates
and I did I did 40 just book updates and
what I would do is every week I would
take I would take
I would take this camera I don't know
how well you guys can see me this is a
big camera I took this camera and walked
down the street with this thing
in my face while people were watching it
was a super terrifying experience I mean
it's not just holding a cell phone I was
like holding this Mega camera and I
would as I walked to Whole Foods because
I wrote my book at Whole Foods in the
cafe as I walked there which was maybe a
20 minute walk I recorded the video of
my update of where I was right now in
the process and then I answered the
questions from last week's video
so whoever commented on this week's
video I would then answer their comments
next week
and so I did I did 40 of those you can
go back and look at it if you look for
these you see the little book icon on it
um and then obviously when I
pre-launched my book and then when the
book is out today so over 40 videos of
me talking about the book
and people are joining you on this
journey of you launching this new
product or what you're doing
you get to talk about your product or
service without talking about your
product or service
right it's not selling it every time but
as people are watching it they're like
oh my God this book is coming out you're
building up all this anticipation
because they've been watching you for
now this was over 40 weeks you might be
able to do it sooner it just took me a
long time to actually you know write the
book and get it up
but show me that behind the scenes
process so that in each of these videos
I'm never really selling the book I mean
maybe in in these two like pre-launch of
the book hey there's some bonuses and
the typical video and the book is out
today and if you order now you're gonna
get all these bonuses great but most of
the content here was about me just
showing why I'm writing the book what
where I'm where I gotta win hey we got a
publisher or where I got a loss like oh
my God my publisher hates what I wrote
and and the editing and they don't like
half of my pages and here's where I'm
fighting like you show the real journey
not just the highlights and how great
everything is that makes people
connected to you and again I'm talking
about the book every single step along
the way
today's is that interesting topic so
this is why I love movement makers so
let me let me share my screen how to not
run out of topics or be repetitive so
this is why I love bookmaker so much
because this is a problem that I
struggled with so much when I was making
my first videos I always felt like I'm
saying the same thing again I already
made a video on that a week ago I'm
doing it again but why I love this is I
would have never thought to put this in
any kind of training program
even though I struggled with it so much
I would have never thought to put this
in a training so I love that you guys
are posting your questions and voting on
topics
um and so we're gonna we're gonna dive
into something I have never shared
before
in any of my videos so unique content
for movement makers today uh shout out
to Sam Machado for the topic we're gonna
get really tactical today because I
think it's gonna be really helpful for
anybody who's struggling with I'm
repeating myself or I don't have enough
new ideas for what content I need to
make are we ready we want to dive in get
some Tactics get some strategies all
right all right I love it let's go so
listen guys I checked last night
I have 10 633 videos just on my main
Channel
okay not all of them are public
but we've got over 10 000 videos on the
main Channel alone
there's only so many times you could
talk about belief right there's only so
many unique ideas that you can come up
with at a time I can guarantee you
there's a lot of repeated content themes
in those 10 000 videos so I've gone
through it I've done it I've done the
work I didn't build my channel just
having 14 super unique videos I'm going
to show you guys how to do it too number
one is focus on them this was one of the
things that helped me so much is
recognizing that most of the people who
are watching your content
are new to your Channel
so I pulled this stat last night from my
YouTube channel this is my main Channel
out of the last 116 million views on my
channel 99 million of them almost 80 86
almost are not subscribed to my channel
they're new people
and I had to look at that like go look
at your own channel and you'll see
something like this and this is good
this is a sign of a healthy Channel it
means we're reaching new people we're
growing more people are finding out
about us if this was flipped I'd be
scared if it's 85 subscribed that's bad
that means nobody knew was watching your
content
so when I saw this stat the first time
it made me realize holy cow the person
watching this has no idea who I am
they've never seen my old messages
before and if I made a video a week ago
or three weeks ago or a month ago or a
year ago chances are they haven't seen
that video and so the message is brand
new for them
this is also why when we when I lay out
in in and build the serve the thought
leadership template
you lead with a powerful opinion because
when most when you say hey guys welcome
back it's me Drew and I'm so excited to
have you here people are watching like
well I don't know who you are welcome
back welcome back to what right they
don't know who you are and so you're
talking to the 15 or the 14 if I had led
my video saying hello welcome back it's
me Evan so excited to have you happy
Thursday I'm talking to this 14 as
opposed to the 85 percent so just
because you feel like you've talked
about it before it doesn't mean that
people have heard it
it's always a brand new
our audience each time just try to
remember that the people watching this
video they don't know who you are they
haven't seen your other videos even in
looking at tests and and how much he's
grown over the past 38 videos I asked
hey have you gotten better she's like
yes I've gotten so much better big smile
not in her head the video that you made
even on the same topic you could do
better now
and that's only 38 videos in once you
get to 100 videos or a thousand videos
if you get the 10 000 videos you get a
lot better in the process you can go
back and watch all of my old videos and
see how bad I was at the beginning and
how I've gotten better
um with practice
okay so always remember that it's a new
audience every time the other thing is
remember that they still need it
right this was another big breakthrough
for me is just because they heard the
message once doesn't mean now okay I got
it now I'm good now I'm set for the rest
of my life right they need it they need
it daily
so this is a great quote that I pulled
from Zig Ziglar who says people often
say motivation doesn't last well neither
does bathing that's why we recommend it
daily
so looking at any of the content that
you're making
if I look at Zen talking about
confidence just because they watch one
video from Zayn on confidence that might
shift him in the moment but if they
don't have it on a regular basis they're
going to fall back
because think about people being a
product of their environment right
that's why I love movement makers and
having you guys here because you can
collab with each other and be supportive
of each other because you have we have a
family environment most people's
environments think about not you now but
think about your audience most of their
environments are not amazing they don't
have people encouraging them they don't
have people believing in them they don't
have people telling them they could be
awesome that their ideas can happen that
they should have courage that they
should chase their goals most of the
people are telling them that their ideas
are that their ideas are very good that
you can't do it that who are you to
think you can go off and do that thing
and so they need you there's a lot of
people writing to me every day we see it
in the comments of how uh I've been the
biggest influence in their life it's
like I don't even know you
right you think about like the their
parents and their friends and their
grandparents and whoever helped I don't
even know who you are and yet I've been
the biggest influence and I take that as
a big responsibility like oh my gosh I
got to make sure that I I stay on track
you know like parents I know
um put on my videos
in the morning for their kids to watch
because because they say the kids won't
listen to me but when they hear Beyonce
say it or where they hear whoever say it
now they listen teachers play my videos
in their schools
for the same reasons like the kids that
want to listen to me but they'll watch
your videos that's a that's a that's a
big responsibility
but it's recognizing that they need it
daily so the people who are watching
your content they need it daily they
need to hear from you daily they might
be subscribing to 200 different channels
you're one of many
and so your content really really really
really matters if I don't post a video
like my espresso Series where we do a
shot events pressed in the morning we
post it Monday to Friday
the amount of comments and the amount of
people write in to say Evan we need a
Saturday in espresso we need a Sunday
espresso none of this weekday only stuff
come on man I need it every day
you know how many videos we have on all
the different channels you're killing me
here but but like that's it people want
it daily if you've if you've shifted
them a little bit in the moment that's a
great shift that's a little baby step
and your goal is to help them make those
little baby steps and baby shifts every
single day
so just because you've said it before it
doesn't mean that they they've they've
Incorporated it they got it and now
they're living it they need that
constant reminder and you making the
content and sharing the message is that
constant reminder to help them be the
the force of influence in their life and
again I take that as a responsibility
and as should you you know for everybody
watching people will consume your
content and be we're building movements
here right movement makers
you're the leader of the movement people
need to hear from you they need to see
you showing up every day with your
message and just the fact that you're
willing to show up is an inspiration
so often we just get too caught up in
our heads of thinking about us well I
already made that video I already said
that I'm out of topics where you have to
shift the Focus right we're built to
serve shifted on them shifted to the
audience they need your help they need
your message they need to hear from you
they need to see you showing up they
need to see you being consistent because
that becomes an inspiration for me to be
consistent as well yeah like we all have
our morning routines and and what I
would love is for you
and your message to be a part of
somebody else's daily routine that's
what building a movement is all about
it's not just randomly watching one of
your videos it's that you become an
integral part of somebody's daily life
that they need you they rely on you
you're the source of inspiration and
courage and belief in them to want to go
and do something bigger in their life
so focusing on them right remember it's
always a new audience
86 percent of my audience and look I'm a
big channel right I've got three million
subscribers almost and still 85 86
percent of the audience are new
and that they need it every single day
and this took me a while I don't really
focus on this anymore but when I was
starting at the beginning I remember
really struggling with this
that like okay I've started I've already
said this before I'm running out of
ideas I don't know what to talk about
that's you getting in your own head you
got to get out of your head and start
focusing on them you focus on them focus
on they need you think about who you
used to be think about how little
influence or positivity you had in your
life and now it's your job to be that
person for the people
we've got a very special topic today the
nine step ultimate coaching process okay
why it matters so first off just quickly
about coaching you guys have heard me
talk about coaching over and over and
over and over and over again I think as
a thought leader it is the most
important thing to be doing at the start
at least of your journey whether you
want to go on and be a coach and that's
part of your your mission amazing but if
not it's still the most important thing
that everybody needs to get some
experience doing the first is content
so I do I do coaching almost every day
live on my Instagram uh here are some
beautiful faces and beautiful people
that have done some recent coaching with
and I do it when I'm you know feeling
great in in uh you know lots of sun on
my face and in a great mood I do it this
was in Puerto Rico and I'm in my
bathrobe doing coaching this is me I'm
looking pretty tired in that shot it
doesn't have to be perfect you don't
have to always look like this you don't
always have to be uh perfect in front of
the camera especially when it's doing it
on Instagram because
the most important thing is you're
teaching me to think like you think so
step number one is just getting content
out there I want you guys to get more
content out there that's the whole
reason for the 100 video challenge you
think differently you have a message to
share
I want other people to understand your
message and so even more powerful than
the thought leadership template that
that we've talked about before that's
been built to serve is you showing me
the results that you can get somebody
that in having a conversation with you
somebody's eyes bug out and say holy cow
I can't believe that's possible
and you're changing that person's life
and then you're also changing anybody
else who's watching they get inspired to
say hmm maybe I can make a change in my
life as well because you had that
conversation this is the number one
piece of advice that I'm giving
all the big names that I work with to
say I need more coaching videos not just
you talking a video all the all the guys
all the and and the ladies who you who
you see on YouTube when you love and you
follow all of them I've I've likely had
a hand in helping their channels grow
and I'm telling them to do more coaching
as the biggest strategy for 2021
it's also a lot easier for people to
show up for you to create content than
to try to memorize a script and just
talk to a camera it's a lot easier to
talk to somebody when you feel like
there's somebody in front of you and
you're helping them it's a lot easier to
do it and you just ask hey how can I
help
you don't have to memorize anything
they're bringing you the content so this
is an easy way to get content out there
to start spreading your message your
mission and and again hopefully people
are asking you questions around what you
know about right when I go live on
Instagram and people come in uh they're
not asking me like how do you braid your
hair
[Laughter]
right they're asking things around
entrepreneurship and personal
development like things that hopefully I
I'm an expert at and know what I'm doing
next it's also the fastest way to make
money so if you guys are in the early
stages and you're trying to turn this
into a full-time business you want to be
able to quit your job and start making
more money for you your family it's the
fastest way before getting to speaking
or books or courses or anything else
it's the fastest way to actually start
making money in your in your business
it's trading your time for money it's
not as efficient but it's the fastest
way to start bringing money in
so this is a picture of um Fonda Fonda
white who he joined my ins my live
stream on YouTube but every four times a
week Zan Drew and I go live on YouTube
answering people's questions and finally
came in and we challenged him to do some
Outreach and DM people on Instagram and
he tried it and he just started dming
some people on Instagram and he got his
first coaching client who signed up for
six months of coaching with them
he told us last night he doesn't even
want to be a coach
that's not part of his long-term
Ambitions it's like here's a guy who
doesn't want to be a coach who's getting
coaching clients just by doing dming on
Instagram so we've got a picture of
Terry Wade Thompson who's here in the
house as well we love you Terry because
in built the serve page 194 is the
strategy it's called the fast pass to
Freedom so it's the dming strategy of
how do I get people to sign up for my
coaching Services it has scripts it has
examples that's in there and that's what
Fonda white was using to go off and get
his clients you can do it too so it's
the fastest way to start making money in
your business
coaching
next you guys want to write books people
here want to write books you want to you
want to be an author you want to write
books
if you do before you write a book
coaching lets you know who you're
talking to so build the serve some here
uh with Dean who's a support of the book
built to serve
basically is a result of all the
coaching that I've done
it's a result of all the conversations
that I have helping entrepreneurs if
you're writing non-fiction right which I
think is where most people are at here
then
coaching allows you to understand the
back and forth so here's what happens
when you have gone through something
yourself you want to share with the
world right you've come through
something you've grown you've learned
now you want to share that with the
world how it worked for you is not going
to be exactly how it works for other
people
and so what you have to understand is
that feedback that they get coming back
to you is the thing that makes you a
better author a better Coach a better
speaker
Etc so when you're writing the book
it's only a one-way conversation
that's a challenge when you're writing
the book it's you only talking to them
there's no feedback
so you have to know what their feedback
is going to be so you can write a better
book
most of what this book is built to serve
is me knowing how people will react to
the message here's a message here's the
who I how and then knowing how people
respond to it and then dealing with
those objections inside the book
so even if your Ambitions are to be a
great author start with being a coach
one example that I shared on my live
stream was Ben Shapiro who if you guys
know him or not he's a he's a right-wing
I don't know what would you call him
he's a personality I guess but he's also
an author and anytime he's writing a new
book he goes on tour across the U.S to
different college campuses with his
thesis of what he wants to write the
book on and he does the town halls which
basically become giant uh debate
sessions he basically wants people to
poke holes in his arguments it's like
tell me why I'm wrong
and what he does is use that feedback to
strengthen his argument to then write a
better book
so in the working with people and
understanding what struggles they're
facing and how they hear your message it
allows you to craft a better message as
opposed to creating in a vacuum most
authors create their book in a total
vacuum and then it doesn't land with
people and they don't end up having the
success that they need
so you have to test drive the messages
first
books are basically group coaching
but there's no feedback so you have to
know what you're doing same thing with
speaking speaking is group coaching
speaking is you're sitting there on a
stage and maybe there's 10 people and
maybe there's 10 000 people in the
audience there's no direct feedback
coming back to you so you have to know
what they're thinking you have to have
done the work on the individual basis
first this is a picture of Lily who I
worked with a number of years ago who
she wanted to be a speaker it's like my
goal is to be a speaker I want to be on
a tedx stage and we got her this is this
is a picture of her on the tedx stage
I said though before you go and be a
speaker you have to be a coach
because you have to know the people in
the audience otherwise your message will
not lend same thing for the book
she'll end up loving coaching so much
that she stopped being a speaker and now
it's just full-time coach
but even if coaching is not your
ultimate ambition
it's your starting point to actually get
to know your audience in a paid way like
there's a big difference between just
coaching somebody for free and coaching
somebody who's willing to pay you
and then everything else that you're
trying to create your course is anything
else you'll make a better course if
you've done coaching you'll make a
better book a better speaking gig better
course all of it if you've done coaching
and this is a huge mistake that people
fall into is you start creating a course
or you start making your topic for your
speech you haven't test driven it enough
on individual people to help them get
results your job as a as a speaker as a
course creator as a book is to help
people get a result
they're coming here with this problem
which is a problem you saw you saw for
yourself and you need to get them from
here to solving the problem
and if it was just as simple as do these
four steps then people would do it and
everybody would be rich and thin and
happy and and all of it the problem is
you're dealing with humans
who will have objections who will have
their own logical process and emotional
process and so you have to understand
how to navigate that
and you can't navigate that unless
you're actually coaching people so it's
super important it's why we're going to
spend some extra time on this because I
really want you uh to get it now let's
get to how to actually do it create a
safe space this is super super important
most people feel like they're being
judged
people are being judged constantly
people being judged by their spouses by
their kids by their parents by their
friends by their teachers by their like
they're all they're all
in this big ball of judgment constantly
your job is to not judge them
your job is to create that safe space
your job is no matter what they say and
some things are easy to not judge for
and some things are harder to not judge
for like if somebody came to you if you
want to be a great coach if somebody
came to you and told you something that
they did that you would never do
you know
um I cheated on my wife as an example
right like that would destroy me
but I'm not going to judge them for that
off the bat because if they feel the
Judgment then I can't help them they're
not going to grow
most people are are really afraid to
tell anybody about the things that are
going on in their life
they barely want to admit it to
themselves
and now you're asking them to tell a
stranger
what ends up happening in a lot of these
sessions is people will tell you things
that they've never told anybody else
they will tell you things that they've
kept hidden that their spouses don't
know their parents don't know their
family doesn't know like nobody knows
and now they're here telling you because
you created that space for them
a lot of it is just in the intention
it's how you show up it's the vibe it's
even even look at how we started
movement makers for for those who are
new here you join early you see Zen
welcome everybody playing some music
he's got the Happy song on he's when I
first joined he had Caribbean music
going it's like it creates the stage
so what's the stage that you're setting
for people and it's just how you show up
if you're showing up you know angry then
they're gonna be they're going to be a
little more on guard if they feel any
kind of judgment they're going to feel a
little more on guard and not share what
you need to share
one of my favorite exercises to do and I
forget who who uh taught me this it
wasn't around coaching even it was just
a recipe for happiness is
imagine you love this person
and this is what I would do
uh and still do when I'm walking down on
the street and I see some stranger
in my head as a quick two second
exercise I love this person
it sounds really weird and cheesy but
if you imagine this person walking down
the streets like I love this person you
just show up differently instead of like
head down in your phone trying to ignore
everybody it's like you're a little more
happy and you might give a smile doesn't
mean you go up and like hug some total
random stranger and
have them punch you or something uh but
that that intention shift makes a big
big big big difference so even as a
little mental reset before you go into
doing a coaching session say I love this
person I want them to win I'm here to
serve them
and just those four seconds of intention
helps you show up better and set the
stage for them to share something that
they may have never shared before
this is the official title today
structuring content delivery to keep it
engaging keep the viewers watching and
informative I uh I shrunk that title
down a little bit to just structuring
engaging content hopefully you guys are
okay with that I want you to use the
right hooks part of the thing that
people struggle with is you have great
content you have great ideas you got a
great heart you want to serve you know
there's there's millions of people who
currently are who you used to be right
and they need your message they need
your voice they need you to get out
there and start to spread it
the challenge is for so many people and
I've seen this over and over and over
and over and over and over again the
intro just sucks the beginning is just
not good enough and you might be making
a 10 minute 20 minute hour long video
with so much gold so much content so
much amazing things inside it
but if the beginning sucks people tune
out this is especially on YouTube where
we go long form on the videos right so
if you guys are making content I see I
see you guys making content too I see
you guys up in your game I see you guys
making some some more videos I'm
thinking of actually doing some kind of
challenge or some tracking of who's
making videos on Instagram live and
YouTube on a consistent basis so we can
all kind of push each other to do a
little bit more but I see you guys doing
it
the beginning Zone this isn't just you
this is
these are these are Big Time
entrepreneurs people who you look up to
respect love that I've been helping
behind the scenes and it's the same
thing I look at the beginning of their
videos and they all suck meanwhile 20
minutes in there's gold that nobody gets
to because people have abandoned the
video so it's really really really
important that you lead with the hook
right we've talked before about in
YouTube having a thumbnail having a
title how to do it but the lead of any
video not just
not just YouTube Instagram videos
Twitter videos a headline on a website
the subject line in an email when you
get on stage what's the first thing that
comes out of your mouth like learning to
lead with something powerful that
connects with people that makes them
wake up pay attention and want to watch
the rest of your content so there's two
main divides that I use here
the first is coming up and the second is
thought leadership so the coming UPS is
you take highlights of the video and you
put it in the beginning so think about
the first 15 to 30 seconds of a video
should be highlights of what's inside
the video think about TV think about uh
you know whatever your favorite program
is
they often will say coming up on
whatever right or even last time on
whatever the show is to kind of get you
primed for what's going on this is when
you cannot control the situation
so when it's just you talking to the
camera you can control it you get to
talk to camera you get to figure out
what your first sentence is going to be
you can control that we'll talk about
that that's thought leadership but when
you're creating content that you cannot
control
you need to have the coming UPS and
that's usually when it involves somebody
else so interviews right if you're
having an interview of somebody on your
show uh if you look at my model the
Master Series right I've had Tony
Robbins on and garyvee on we have
garyvee coming up again we just had Tony
uh we just said Wim Hof on group of Paul
Das Seth Godin often the beginning of
any interview is not fantastic it's it's
report building it's getting to know you
it's it's just setting the stage it's
asking how you're doing it's what's
happening in Corona for you right now
right it's it's just setting the stage
and it's not gold bombs dropping yet
but in the middle of the video there's
going to be amazing ones that come up so
you take the highlights and put it to
the beginning live stream same thing
somebody live streams suck live streams
at the beginning you're you're welcoming
people you're saying hi uh what Zayn was
doing was awesome right dancing and
welcoming people and having some music
on and saying turn your camera on like
hey how are you doing what's going on
spreading the energy and I've seen the
live chat people thinking Zayn for the
energy uh at the beginning
but I wouldn't want to put that up as a
video right like that's an experience
between you guys and Zen but not a great
start for a video that people would want
to watch so even this I started the
recording so that you guys could have it
after you know once I came on camera and
said hey Movie Makers let's go right so
most live streams at the beginning
really suck you can train yourself
to lead with your powerful opinion you
could train yourself to turn live
streams into uh thought leadership
pieces and if any of you are doing live
streams I would recommend trying to
train yourself to go on an opening
monologue so if you remember back to Jay
Leno and David Letterman I don't know if
that I don't know if the new talk show
hosts are still doing it but they open
with a monologue
so you're opening with a monologue
You're diving right into the idea that
you have before you start to welcome
people and say hey how you doing and all
this kind of stuff so there's nobody
watching the beginning of a live stream
right it's just you and then people
slowly start to join have in your mind
I'm gonna do a two to five minute
monologue on something that I care
deeply about so if you're not going to
edit anything out at the end that's
going to be a really good way to get
people in on the replay you're always
thinking for the replay value not for
the live stream value
coaching I want everybody doing coaching
uh it's great practice it's also great
content but again at the beginning of a
coaching session it sucks because you're
getting to know the person you're
waiting you're waiting for them to join
and you're asking some get to know you
questions creating the safe space all
that but it's not amazing content yet so
again the highlights go to the beginning
so Vlogs documentaries we haven't gone
super deep into but if you're if you're
having either somebody follow you around
and make content or if you're following
your own day around you may not know
what's going to happen during the day
that's part of the problem of creating
the vlogger or documentary you're you're
figuring out as you go so even if you
have an idea for what you're gonna do
you don't know what the main theme is
going to be until you actually start
living so again usually the beginning
sucks of that video but there's going to
be some highlight moment take it to the
beginning and then speeches is a little
bit of a tricky one because I think when
you are getting on stage and doing
speeches
you should be thinking about leading
with a powerful opinion uh you should be
thinking about turning into thought
leadership content uh you can be
welcoming people but at every second you
spend welcome people saying thank you
it's great to be here all that stuff uh
takes away from replay value so if
that's how you're going to open again
coming up put it to the beginning
okay so there may be a couple others but
basically it's when you're involving
other people
it's harder to control the setting and
it might be rude in the live experience
to go right to you know the powerful
opinion uh so we're we're using coming
ups and again big big entrepreneurs are
still making this mistake with their
videos
the thought leadership stuff we've
talked a bit about and so I don't need
to dive super deep into but I want to go
through some examples so you guys get it
and that picture by the way is is me
um it's an interview I did that Tony
Robbins put up at his business Mastery
Program
uh so that was you know super humbling
super fun opportunity everything's
moving virtual now
so these are now Zoom uh sessions and
that's Tony in the middle
um kind of sitting down watching the
interview happen
so thought leadership is what you can
control
and what we want to do is be thinking
about leading with a powerful opinion so
the first thing out of your mouth wants
to be needs to be must be
a powerful opinion something you believe
that other people don't believe what do
you believe so from the second that you
press record
what do you believe that other people
don't believe and most people when
they're doing this it's the high welcome
back it's me Susie so excited I'm here
to see you and I'm going to talk right
and people are gone first
they're already gone like five seconds
ten seconds in if you don't give them
something immediate they're going to be
gone the thing though is people will go
especially to YouTube for education
people who are saying well people have
short attention spans
it's not true uh people will go for
Education just like you might sit down
and watch a four-hour Star Wars movie
and watch the whole thing
but you won't watch a 30 second ad that
you hate that is not relevant to you so
it's not just about short attention span
it's about giving people value people
will go especially to YouTube looking
for Value looking for Content looking
for a message that can help them solve a
problem so don't be afraid to go long
form but we need to hook them right away
with something that's going to make them
want to stick and what we found is and
I'll talk about it coming up but in that
first minute if you can get them for the
first minute
if you can commit for them to watch one
minute of you
they're gonna stick
in that first minute is really where
they're making that decision do I do I
want to spend more time they're giving a
little bit I don't know
and then if they like it they're gonna
keep watching and if they don't they're
gonna go find somebody else right it's
it's one click away to go find another
video or another piece of content or
another you know swipe to go find
something else so in that first minute
super super important that we
that we keep their attention and so
powerful opinion context sentence and
raise the stakes
what do you believe that other people
don't believe that if you walk down the
street and said this people think you're
weird and you are weird this is this is
great congratulations you're weird
you're weird doc this is awesome this is
the whole point you think differently
than other people this is your job is to
teach other people to think like you
think
the context sentence you just told me
something that was weird that was
different you kind of hurt my brain a
little bit like what did what did she
just say what did he just say the
contact sentence give me a little bit
more perspective on what that means and
then raise the stakes you basically are
showing what happens to me if I don't if
I don't take action on this because you
your goal is to get people to watch your
video and then do something the more you
can move people into action the more
people are going to follow you the more
people are gonna see you as being their
guide and Mentor the more you're gonna
feel
amazing because you're helping people
get results instead of just motivating
people
so
your goal after people watch the video
is for them to do something where it's
so easy to fall back into their regular
life
so this video matters you have to go
even into the recording of this video
that this video matters what I'm about
to make today is going to change
somebody's life
and that might be hard to think when you
just in your office on a trampoline just
pressing record on the video but this
video literally could be changing and
saving somebody's life
and so you have to come in with that
that mindset that importance that
urgency on your end before you go uh so
powerful opinion context sentence racist
takes make it important tell me what
happens if I don't follow through
if you want to watch the full version of
this video as well as train live with me
twice a month to help you build your
movement and be around some other
amazing people just like you check out
my movement makers program the link to
join is right there next to me can't
wait to see you there continue to
believe and go join